okay I do want to follow up about a
pretty big story from last week I told
you last week that some major youtubers
like philip defranco and the young turks
etc started to have some of their videos
demonetised and what this means is when
we upload a video to YouTube we tell the
the the YouTube system yes
display ads on this video that's how we
make money some youtubers started to see
individual videos demonetised and we put
up a graphic which sort of explained
what was going on saying that in order
to monetize a video it must be
advertiser friendly and contain no
graphic content or excessive strong
language that generally speaking makes
sense and has been the policy for a
while however we also saw this other
screenshot that has started to circulate
saying that even discussing
controversial or sensitive subjects and
events including those related to war
conflict natural disaster or stretch or
tragedy may be deemed not advertiser
friendly and not monetizable even
without showing graphic imagery YouTube
came out and said no no no we haven't
changed the policy all we've changed is
how we notify people when their videos
have been demonetised I now have
evidence to present to you that says it
is not just a policy change because for
videos from recent weeks have now been
demonetised for us you'll notice here
the yellow dollar sign which says that
our our video which involves a
discussion of preventing child abuse
with childlike dolls has been
demonetised you will also see in this
next screenshot next to the yellow
dollar sign that our video about the
California rape bill that was inspired
by the Stanford rape case has also been
demonetized although we show no graphic
imagery it is a discussion of a
legislative act done by California that
video is no longer earning revenue for
us you will also see that our video on
North Korea firing a ballistic missile
has been demonetized nothing even
remotely graphic there no descriptions
of injuries or anything a discussion of
it
that the North Korean regime has made
nope apparently that is not okay to earn
revenue on YouTube and lastly our video
on marijuana being a Schedule one drug
making absolutely no sense that has also
been demonetised
apparently because it refers to the fact
that marijuana exists this is not a
violation of free speech right this is
not an attack on anyone's First
Amendment rights this is a way in which
now an outlet YouTube has expanded their
Terms of Service which they absolutely
can do to subtly push in one direction
the stories that are done now we can
continue covering all of the exact same
stories that we normally would knowing
that some of them because they are
apparently too controversial even though
we don't swear because we're on radio
and TV and we abide by FCC language
guidelines and we don't show graphic
disgusting gory images we are still not
going to be able to monetize those
videos my goal would be because of
membership support that hey you know
what if one or two stories a week if
four or five stories a week eight or
nine stories a week or demonetised if
those are stories I want to do I'm going
to do them because it is not going to
affect our total revenue that's
significantly but there are other
channels who could say you know these
are stories that deserve to be covered
but I've got to pay the bills we've got
to pay staff we've got to pay rent we've
got to pay whatever and it is a way in
which the term the application of the
Terms of Service can start to manage the
messaging that is out there I don't like
this fortunately we have membership
revenue and people can sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership that is the
best way to keep us unaffected by these
d monetization I don't know what else to
say it's sad what's going on yeah just
just uh yeah big brother is watching
he's not letting you you know commit any
face crimes or talk about anything
that's apparently anti governmental
anything to do with sex or you know
sexism
it's just rugs in this particular case
yeah North Korea in this particular case
yes so really people who know this show
know that we don't do the sensationalist
Gore porn or detailed descriptions of
sexual acts or whatever we're really
conscious of
because we are on broadcast radio and TV
and apparently at least on some issues
the guidelines now on YouTube are even
more strict than those on broadcast
television or TV where there's been no
problem with our discussions of drugs
North Korean policy etc very very
disturbing and we're going to continue
following it